[Music]
so there's a tremendous amount of fraud
in the prescription drug marketplace
right and just like with provenance
tracking of diamonds or of the the food
supply chain you could have provenance
tracking for pharmaceuticals right you
could have a system whereby the drugs
from the time they're manufactured and
the batch that they were made in and the
factory they were made in right we're
tracked in some way that maybe parts of
that Republic maybe parts of it were
private but we're tracked through the
distribution process to to the end
recipient now obviously when we're
talking about individual patients and
the prescriptions that they get that is
highly sensitive data right that's data
that you wouldn't ever store directly in
a chain you know know what your
prescription is what my prescriptions
are that sort of thing but tracking
these objects as they're tracking these
individual vials of a drug or you know
bottles of a drug as they get down to
the pharmacy level is something that
that we can do to try to see where are
their pharmacies that seem to be
dispensing a lot more than they should
be based on the prescriptions that
they're receiving right furthermore
finding ways to actually measure so
maybe separate from the opioid crisis
but we actually have a challenge of
adherence in the drug industry right
understanding for a given prescription
drug who's actually taking that at the
times they should be taking it at the
you know and continuing to take the full
regimen rather than stopping halfway
through because they felt okay right and
so you could see IOT sensor data from
the dispenser devices themselves weaving
together a picture that allows us to see
all the way from the batch the drug was
made into the people who were prescribed
it and who took it if there is a problem
out there if there is a quality control
issue where did that come from and who
might be responsible for that right and
correspondingly the patients who do it
here well are they are they benefiting
from the use of those drugs or the ones
who are having poor reactions the ones
who are only taking half their
prescription that sort of thing
bringing it back to the the opioid
crisis I think you know tracking
prescriptions in a system like this if
we can find ways to do it
respect patient confidentiality right
I'm a huge believer in the importance of
keeping the patient at the center of who
their information is being shared with
and on what basis right but if we can
build kind of an airtight system for for
tracking all that and understanding
where these prescriptions are going
we'll have a much better basis for
discovering fraud all right
discovering places where there might be
fraud and it's worth deeper
investigation all right and and trying
to understand how do we how do we get to
I tend not to blame the drug taker I
think they're just medicating to meet
their needs it's really the distributors
and those writing fake prescriptions and
others who are enabling a lot of this
crisis that and I think a uh I think
distributed ledger technology can help
us understand where where there might be
abuses in that system so we have a
number of healthcare organizations in
our community we have a company called
Kaiser all right really big on the west
coast I think out here
they're known as well change healthcare
which is a part of McKesson and a lot of
startups and they're looking at a number
of different use cases in the healthcare
sector from supply chain provenance and
pharmaceuticals to provider directories
which are basically these directories of
doctors and the certifications that
they've been awarded and are they
keeping up with their yearly kind of you
know ten hours of Education and those
types of things right to two
prescriptions and then really the the
big kind of Holy Grail is medical
records right can we make medical
records more portable not by publishing
them into a distributed ledger because
again the whole point of a distributed
ledger is push this data out widely but
instead by creating wallets of health
information for individuals right that
keep track of your records that operates
somewhat like a Bitcoin wallet right
where you know you have these assets and
you can decide to share these records
with you receive them from one doctor
you could decide to share them with
another doctor you could I would if you
moved and you had to change doctors
change health care providers you could
bring that data with you and what would
be tracked on ledger is a pointer to
your wallet and a signature for each of
the records you have that attests to the
actual data right so if I get a
I can't change you know that entry from
ten pills to a hundred pills right
because that would change the signature
and the signature is what would be
recorded in the change in the ledger
right so all of these kinds of questions
about trust and provenance and discovery
right understanding where is all my data
right and being able to bring that
together and view the patient as the
center of health information exchange is
a problem that we didn't haven't been
able to solve when we approached health
IT as a point two point integration
challenge we or left it up to the
patient to cart around big boxes of
paper records or CD ROMs right but I
think we can really make a dent in it
with with distributed ledger technology
and many of our companies are working on
that with that very challenge
[Music]